give directly is the non-profit that
lets you send cash directly to the
world's poorest household which is more
cost effective than so many other types
of giving it's how you know you're
maximizing your donations help us reach
our goal of fifteen thousand dollars by
the end of the year go to give
directly.org Pacman
and welcome to the David Pacman show I'm
producer Pat Ford filling in for David
today as he is spending some time today
on the studio redesign you may know by
now that we're coming out with the new
studio for you guys in the next few I
don't know weeks months something like
that and the panels are going right in
the trash no more panels we're gonna be
doing something new so he's working on
that today he'll be back with us
tomorrow I wanted to start things off
today by talking about this big story we
heard over the long holiday weekend here
in the United States and that is that
Kanye West was seen with Nick Fuentes at
an airport together and it was confirmed
that they were going to visit Donald
Trump the failed former president at
Mar-A-Lago now this is a big deal of
course because Nick Fuentes is a flat
out racist anti-semitic person political
commentator he's so far to the right
that either even other people on the
right denounce him because you know he's
just full mask off right he's a
holocaust denier he wants Trump to be
made dictator like all the worst things
that you can get on the right Kanye West
of course is the famous rapper who
decided to throw his career away earlier
this month and become a social prior
also that he could you know publicly say
these anti-semitic things and claim that
he was going to go death Con 3 on Jewish
people so Trump thought that it would be
a good idea to have dinner with these
two people and as you may imagine the
Trump 2024 presidential campaign team is
going absolutely ballistic over this
they're in full-on damage control mode
because this is just not the right way
to start off your campaign dining with a
couple of out and out anti-semites so
Trump put out a statement about all this
on Truth social and this is how it all
got organized according to him he said
quote this past week Kanye West called
me to have dinner at Mar-A-Lago shortly
thereafter he unexpectedly showed up
with three of his friends whom I knew
nothing about we had dinner on Tuesday
evening with many members present on the
back patio the dinner was quick and
uneventful they then left for the
airport so Trump here being very much
dismissive of the 3p people that Kanye
brought with him to the dinner he's
trying to say oh well I can't be guilty
by association because I didn't even
know these people but really just having
Kanye over alone is enough to make you
worthy of public scrutiny it's a sign
that you've gone too far because he's
just said some horrible things over the
past few weeks that have rightfully got
him canceled in all these things about
he always gonna go death Con 3 on Jewish
people and all these anti-semitic tropes
that he repeats and repeats and it's not
like one of those things where you have
a celebrity who says something dumb and
then they apologize for it the next day
they say oh I was drunk when I wrote
that that's not how I really feel and
I'm going to make every effort to make
amends no Kanye has just said horrible
things and continued saying horrible
things he keeps doubling down on these
shows and on Twitter and all these
different stuff so I mean having Kanye
over at this point it's just completely
toxic you used to be able to trot him
around in these right wing circles like
Candace Owens would go around the
country with him and there was talk
about how he's a trump supporter and you
know he'd go on Tucker Carlson show and
all these different things you really
can't be associated with him anymore
even if you're on the right so this
excuse that Trump gives that oh I only
knew Kanye I didn't know the other
visitors Kanye is enough to make you
look bad there's also a great amount of
dispute over whether Trump actually
didn't know the other three guests that
Kanye brought with him since Karen
Giorno was one of them and she was
Trump's campaign director in the State
of Florida in 2016. he apparently knows
her by name and site so if he lied about
that what else could he be lying about
it I get the sense that he probably knew
who Nick Fuentes was even though he
declares that he didn't know who Nick
Fuentes was maybe he knew that Fuentes
isn't the type of person you don't want
to admit to knowing but I do get the
sense that Trump probably knew who he
was Fuentes was there by the way because
he was advising Kanye West in yay's 2024
presidential campaign which we found out
about last week that that's a thing that
Kanye is giving another shot at becoming
presidents and he has people like Nick
Fuentes and Milo yiannopoulos working
for him as for the dinner Trump had
planned to dine privately with Kanye at
mar-a-lago's library but then they
decided that they should all eat outside
on the public patio no word yet as to
what they had for dinner I don't know
about the appetizer and entree selection
but who knows maybe we'll get some more
updates on that but as to what they
talked about at the dinner Kanye
actually had the gall to ask Trump to be
his running mate during this whole
exchange so Kanye invited himself over
effectively to Trump's house at least
that's the theory that we have that's
the story we're being told on this and
he decided to tell Trump who he knows is
running for president himself that he
Kanye West is also running for president
and may take some share of the Trump
vote and then on top of that Kanye wants
Trump to bend the knee to him at his own
house and become his vice president like
how crazy is that Kanye just full of
arrogance here not understanding that
Trump is the alpha a dog currently in
Republican politics and he's not just
going to back Kanye for no reason and
become his VP just absolutely insane you
cannot make this stuff up folks and we
actually have Kanye talking about his
encounter with Trump let's cut to that
now and listen to some of the other
things that Kanye says went down at that
dinner I think the thing that Trump was
most perturbed about me asking him to be
my vice president I think that was like
lower on the list of things that caught
him off guard then he goes on to say
that Kim is a
you could tell her I said that and I was
thinking like that's the mother of my
children since we know and all the
Christians in America that love Trump
know that Trump is a conservative we're
going to demand that you hold all
policies directly to the Bible when
Trump started basically screaming at me
at the table telling me I was going to
lose I mean has that ever worked for
anyone in history
I'm like hold on hold on you're talking
to yay so there's that trademark
arrogance on display with Kanye West he
thinks he can just show up to Trump's
Residence at Mar-A-Lago and ask him to
be his VP and that Trump wouldn't get
mad or anything like that of course
Trump got mad because he has this giant
ego and both of these people have crazy
egos like if you put them in a room
together some wacky situation is going
to stir up and in this case it was not a
room but a back patio but nonetheless
some crazy things resulted from it also
pretty wild if we're to believe Kanye
that Trump would attack Kim Kardashian
for no apparent reason no relevant
reason anyway and we also learned from
this campaign ad we just watched that
Kanye West wants to make America a
Theocratic Nation to be a Christian
Nation and uh it's just added layers of
what's a crazy story that we don't even
have time to get into today the fact
that Trump apparently attacked Kim
Kardashian and the fact that Kanye wants
to make the US a nationalist country or
a a Christian nationalist country rather
so Trump is full on in damage control
because uh his campaign must have gone
to him and said you know you really
should not have had these people over so
he took to truth social yesterday to
respond to some of the backlash about
Kanye and he couldn't even really do
that properly because he brought up
Kanye's race for no apparent reason he
said this quote so I help a seriously
troubled man who just happens to be
black yay Kanye West who has been
decimated in his business and virtually
everything else and he was always been
good to me by allowing his request for a
meeting at Mar-A-Lago alone so that I
can give him very much needed advice so
Trump effectively here saying that he
doesn't care that Kanye has said these
horrible anti-semitic things because
he's been nice to Trump and that's all
that matters in Trump's world now the
other key takeaway from the dinner is
that Trump was reportedly very much
impressed with Nick Fuentes he said
something like he really gets me and he
seemed very much taken by Fuentes who
was able to Rattle off statistics and
recall speeches quotes from Trump's
speeches going back to his 2016
presidential campaign at one point Trump
asked Fuentes what he thought about his
presidential announcement speech that he
gave a couple of weeks ago and Fuentes
said that he should rely Less on the
teleprompter and he needed to be higher
energy which actually was true Trump was
very much low energy in that
announcement speech Fuentes also told
Trump that he's going to crush the
competition in the 2024 election
DeSantis included which as you might
imagine Trump like very much but it all
just adds a very strange layer of
complexity to this because Fuentes is
supposedly there because he's advising
Kanye West for for Kanye's presidential
campaign so why is he giving Trump
pointers and telling him he's going to
crush the competition and all these
different things like this is just a
complete Gong Show here Trump also asked
if Fuentes was on Truth social which he
said Nick Nick said that he is on Truth
social uh and a bunch of other social
media sites had kicked him off for being
too quote Fringe so that all in all was
the dinner there's still the question
over how much the Trump campaign is
going to be affected by this like will
Republicans even care about this sort of
thing because like Trump will repeatedly
routinely make these unforced errors do
stuff like this where he shoots himself
in the foot and he'll just be able to
get Beyond it like people forget about
it after a few weeks or so every time we
wonder us on the left like will this
time be different will this be one of
the things where where Trump went too
far and even Republicans turn on him but
it never happens it at least hasn't
happened for the past six years and
there's been some crazy things going on
in that six years like coup attempts and
these types of things
will this be any different my initial
sense is no but on the other hand if
there's a case to be made for this
actually torpedoing Trump's early
chances here of at least you know just
drowning out the competition and having
an easy road to the nomination it's that
he's already a wounded Antelope like he
had a disastrous midterm performance so
many of his candidates lost in their
midterm bids the Murdoch's aren't
supporting him anymore so he's not
getting favorable coverage on places
like Fox News he is Ron DeSantis surging
behind him in the polls and in the
betting markets some polls and betting
odds even have the santis up and there's
just not a lot of energy behind Trump's
2024 campaign so there's the potential
that in an environment like this where
Trump is already doing so poorly and has
so many different things working against
him maybe this is the type of thing that
can get a lot of attention and diminish
his hopes of being able to make a lock
on this thing like to just completely
secure the nomination for himself any
other politician this would probably
torpedo their chances but we've seen
Trump get Beyond these types of things
before and ultimately he'll probably be
able to do it again all right we're
going to go to a break now we'll be back
with much more of the David Pacman show
right after this I have done a ton of
reading about how to optimize charitable
donations we all have some limited
amount we can give and for me it's
important to make sure I'm giving in the
most efficient way when organizations
give cash to families in need about 90
cents on the dollar actually goes to the
recipient instead of only about 50 cents
of relative impact with some of the more
complex programs like certain kinds of
job training for example that's why I
reached out to an amazing non-profit
called give directly about partnering
with us because give directly lets you
send cash directly to the world's
poorest households the David packman
show is trying to hit fifteen thousand
dollars in donations to give directly
before the year is up that's equal to
about a Year's worth of expenses and
Investments for 15 families in many
cases use the link below giving families
cash lets them choose for themselves how
to improve their lives they buy food
they repair their homes they start a
business they buy medication they pay
for their kids schools give directly is
doing truly incredible work all around
the world when you give to them you're
maximizing every hard-earned dollar that
you donate and they need your help go to
give
directly.org Pacman help us get to
fifteen thousand dollars by the end of
the year the link is down below
we know that Republicans are going to be
taking over the House of Representatives
at the start of 2023 and so that means
that for Democrats there's not too many
working days remaining on the
Congressional calendar to get the things
that you want to get past past and it
means that these next few weeks we have
to be all hands on deck to get these
pieces of legislation through and get
them signed into law luckily we'll still
have the Senate after the start of 2023
but we're not gonna have the house
anymore and really these opportunities
where you have full control of
government the house senate and
presidency don't happen too often and so
you have to make the best of the time
where you have it all we have a few more
weeks and so it's time to get busy my
hope is that with this added sense of
urgency we'll be able to get the votes
we need on some of these things and also
you don't have to worry as much about
some of these more vulnerable senators
and Congress people because they don't
have to worry about an election for
another couple years at least so maybe
you'll have more votes post midterms
than you had pre-mid terms Chuck Schumer
is saying about this lame duck period we
are going to try to have as productive a
lame duck session as possible it's going
to be heavy work long hours to try and
get something done let's hope he can
deliver on this I anticipate that he's
going to run into many of the same
issues that we've had over these past
couple of years which is that you can't
always get everyone on the exact same
page because you have slim majorities to
work with in the House and Senate now in
these next few weeks there's some must
Do's in the agenda some things that
Democrats actually absolutely have to
get done like for example they're going
to need to pass legislation to keep the
government open and funded in order to
avoid a government shutdown they also
have to pass the National Defense
authorization act that has to get passed
so that the military can get funded and
you better bet that we're going to be
able to find the money to do that
because that is always a top priority in
Washington there's also this back and
forth about raising the debt limit from
its current
31.4 trillion dollar cap Republicans may
try to hold this hostage in exchange for
some concessions on spending cuts to be
honest the debt ceiling talk and the
government shutdown talk it doesn't
interest me that much because these
things happen like every couple of years
maybe even more frequently than that and
it's always the same discussion we
always know that they're going to do the
right thing to keep the government open
and so that we won't default on our debt
and all these different things but it's
just this big charade that comes up I'm
more focused on the policy items that
Democrats can get done in these next
couple of weeks um like for one they
still have to codify interracial
marriage and same-sex marriage they had
that preliminary vote on the topic and
12 Republicans in the Senate crossed
over and voted along with the Democrats
but they still need to pass this thing
one more time in the Senate hopefully
that's a shoe-in my sense is that it is
in terms of other priorities they have
to
pass some legislation to clarify the
Electoral count Act of 1887 which became
a point of interest when Trump was
trying to overturn the 2012 20 election
results Democrats want to clarify the
vice president's role as purely
ceremonial when they count the electoral
votes of course it was believed for many
many years to be ceremonial but then
Trump decided to torpedo democracy and
argued that Pence was able to overturn
the election in his favor and so
Democrats want to make the text very
much clear on how you count electoral
votes so that a vice president can't
just turn things over so that they win
this is what Trump interpreted to be
Vindication by the way because he was
trying to claim that the whole time Mike
Pence set the authority to do this and
the fact that Democrats are changing the
law now means that he was right that
Pence could have done this and
it doesn't really make any sense but
anyway they're trying to do that they're
also looking at getting more Aid
approved for Ukraine especially with the
expectation that Kevin McCarthy is not
going to be amenable to approving more
Aid funding uh for Ukraine once the
Republicans take over there's
contingents on the right these
non-infudentialist types also these
people who think that we shouldn't help
Ukraine at all in their fight against
the Russian invasion for one reason or
another because they're okay with
Putin's regime they're not going to want
to see Aid going towards Ukraine so
that's another thing that Democrats can
try to do one last-ditch effort on that
they're also trying to get protections
for dreamers with these final few weeks
undocumented immigrants who were brought
to the U.S as minors even though they
didn't make the decision on their own to
come here they still have to deal with
you know potential deportation
potentially going back to a country that
they never knew because they weren't
born here in the United States and
aren't technically citizens so that's
another thing that Biden should try to
do in these next few weeks I I think
that personally if you're going to go
pedal to the metal on any of these
issues it should probably be the
dreamers because it's perhaps the most
consequential like the same-sex marriage
thing and interracial marriage build
that'll probably get done pretty easily
I'm also assuming we're going to be able
to keep the government funded and you
know raise the debt ceiling and all
those procedural types of things but in
terms of what you can actually do to
make a material difference for the
public and how you can sort of increase
Democratic poll numbers and just do the
most good with the time that you have
left I think that protecting the
dreamers should be a high priority I
wish that there could be more things on
this list but you know we've known since
the start of this Congress the start of
this presidency that we were not going
to be able to get done all the
progressive uh wish list items that we
wanted to get accomplished done because
we just we're never going to have the
votes we weren't able to repeal the
filibuster and all this stuff but that
doesn't mean that you can't grab all
these low-hanging fruit that's what
we've been trying to do over these past
couple of years and hopefully with these
final weeks we'll be able to do more of
it student loan payments have been
suspended once again by the Biden
Administration as they have announced
that they are going to push back when
people will have to start making
payments on their bills yet again the
moratorium started in Spring of 2020 of
course with the kova 19 pandemic and the
plan that President Biden unveiled
earlier this year was that in exchange
for the ten thousand dollars of student
loan forgiveness more if you got Pell
Grants that they would bring back the
payments at the start of 2023 but then
we learned that there were these
Republican efforts to challenge Biden's
executive order to forgive the debt and
two of the lawsuits ended up succeeding
at least for now putting on halt uh the
Biden debt relief plan and leaving
millions of Americans in limbo the bind
Administration is saying that they will
resume payments either halfway through
2023 or shortly after the courts ideally
allow his executive order to stand so
depending on what the courts decide to
do is when you may have to start making
payments again if that that type of
thing applies to you Biden is rightfully
playing politics with this of course
saying that if Republicans are going to
tie up what he wants to do in the courts
he's going to use his power to make sure
that at least for now people with
student loans are benefiting from his
presidency it would also be kind of
strange unfair if someone who has let's
say nine thousand dollars worth of
student loan debt all of a sudden has to
start making payments on that balance
again even though they thought that they
wouldn't have to pay it at all they
thought it was all going to get forgiven
and now they still don't even know if
it's going to ultimately get forgiven as
I mentioned there are two cases holding
up the debt relief the first came to us
on November 10th after a right-wing
federal judge in Texas put a halt on the
debt relief plan because they were going
to hear out the case of two borrowers
who didn't qualify for the debt relief
the plaintiffs were of course backed by
conservative groups and then shortly
after that we heard from the U.S court
of appeals in Missouri they granted an
injunction by six red States against the
debt relief plan that one had has to do
with whether Biden has the authority to
do this as president or if he needs
Congressional approval and I gotta say
it pains me to say this but there is a
good chance at least a decent chance
that the courts will end up striking
this down outright because the legal
justification that Biden is using to
forgive the debt is kind of on shaky
grounds like the basis is the 2003
Heroes act which allows the education
department leeway for rules surrounding
student loans if there's a war or
National Emergency in this case the
National Emergency is being cited as
Coba 19 which no doubt would have been
successful maybe back in 2020 2021
during the worst parts of the pandemic
but the courts and especially these
right-wing courts may say that okay well
we're Beyond covet as an emergency it's
one thing to have a pause on payments
during a crisis especially when people
can't work it's a different thing
altogether to forgive debt going forward
and so you really need Congress to pass
this the president can't do this on
their own they there's also the question
about whether this will hurt Republicans
if they're able to torpedo this thing
because you may imagine that they're
going to be plenty of Republican
constituents who would stand to benefit
from student loan forgiveness maybe
they'll look the other way maybe they'll
say that they didn't want it in the
first place and it was unfair or
whatever that type of thing happens you
never know what these Republican
constituents it's also a long time
before they have to vote against not
gonna be another two years before the
2024 election so maybe there won't be
any sort of consequences but hopefully
it doesn't come to that hopefully this
debt relief plan is going to be able to
stand up because ten thousand dollars up
to twenty thousand dollars that can
really do a lot of good for a lot of
people but let me know what you think
will this be allowed to stand up and if
it is struck down will Republicans have
to pay a political price for it with
Republicans taking over the House of
Representatives we expect that the
current House minority leader Kevin
McCarthy is going to become the next
Speaker of the House in fact he got the
nomination of his party earlier this
month by a wide margin 188 to 31 getting
many more times the votes that his
Challenger Andy Biggs got but even so
McCarthy is going to have a tough time
getting to that 218 vote threshold that
you need to become speaker when that
vote takes place on the house floor at
the start of next year and that's
because he has a slim majority to work
with Democrats are of course going to
back Pelosi's successor Hakeem Jeffries
but he's not going to have the 218 votes
that he needs Republicans are going to
have to decide amongst themselves who
the next speaker of the house is so
McCarthy will need nearly all the votes
from the Republican caucus to get him to
that 218 threshold he can only spare to
have about four Republicans vote against
him that's the current projection based
on how some of these elections are
playing out and how big the uh majority
is going to be for the Republicans and
that's going to be a tall task for
McCarthy getting those 31 Republicans
who voted against him in the nomination
process to vote for him to speaker on
the house floor he can only afford to
lose a few and right now he's got to
convince at least a few dozen of them we
already have a number of hard no's from
Republican reps saying that they are not
going to be backing McCarthy many of
these hard no's come to us from the
house Freedom caucus they include people
like Matt Gates Ralph Norman uh Andy
Biggs Matt Rosendale and Representative
Bob good interestingly enough Marjorie
Taylor green not on this list you'd
think that she's so Fringe that of
course she would back whoever is running
against McCarthy but maybe because she's
being promised her committee assignments
back she is saying McCarthy is the
person for the job right now and even
among these hard-nos are they actually
hard nose like they're probably just
using this for leverage in a negotiation
the idea is that maybe they'll end up
giving their votes to McCarthy in
exchange for some concessions like one
thing that's being floated in particular
is to Institute a motion to vacate the
chair which would allow members of the
house to kick out the current Speaker of
the House mid-session so if they got
this in potentially what would happen
would be McCarthy gets elected speaker
he gets enough votes and then after a
short period of period of time the
freedom caucus gets upset with him and
decides to oust him as their leader he's
apparently not in negotiations yet with
the freedom caucus but his hand is
eventually going to be forced like he's
going to have to come to the table and
talk to these people if he wants their
votes McCarthy we know has wanted the
speakership for so long it's been his
ultimate goal in his career and he
nearly got it in 2015 when John Boehner
decided to step down as the leader of
the House Republicans stepped down as
Speaker of the House but then it became
clear that McCarthy was not going to get
the votes that he needed to become
speakers so in came Paul Ryan who was
ushered in as someone who could
represent like the tea party factions
and the freedom caucus factions while
still having appeal to like the broader
Republican party because he was Mitt
Romney's VP candidate in 2012 and so he
was the one guy everyone could agree on
there's talk about that type of
situation happening again to McCarthy
and instead someone like maybe Steve
scalise or Elise stefanik or Jim Jordan
coming in as the person that Republicans
can all coalesce around now another
thing that may damage McCarthy is that
he seems unwilling to impeach Joe Biden
because he kind of gets the political
ramifications that could happen if they
decide to impeach Biden for some absurd
reason especially because Biden hasn't
really done anything impeachable over
these past couple of years especially um
you know relatively speaking in terms of
what you would impeach a president for
some say that he should be impeached for
pulling out of Afghanistan some on the
right are saying that he should be
impeached for inflation some say for
Hunter Biden and the laptop from hell
it's clear the bass just wants to uh
impeach Biden because of Revenge and
they figure okay well Trump got
impeached twice so we got to impeach
Biden in the same way but that could end
up backfiring hugely for them if it's
seen as being done for a nonsense reason
and I kind of get the sense that Kevin
McCarthy understands that he wants to
avoid avoid impeachment altogether if
he's able to but if people are saying
from inside the house that you got to do
it if the constituents the Republican
Party are saying you got to do it maybe
his hand will be forced and he'll have
to do that so Kevin McCarthy in a giant
mess I don't envy his position right now
it's not a shoe-in that he's going to
become the next house speaker but he's
certainly vying for it and we'll see if
it ends up happening we're going to go
to a break right now we'll be back with
much more of the David Pacman show after
these commercial messages
protests have been boiling over in China
against covet restrictions nearly three
years into the covid-19 pandemic in
Shanghai and in universities across the
country we're hearing of demonstrations
people chanting things like step down Xi
Jinping step down Communist party also
chance like we don't want kova tests we
want freedom and we don't want
dictatorship we want democracy police
are arresting people at these protests
trying to send a message to people to
stand down and stay home and their
videos of police dragging away
protesters beating protesters I won't
subject you to them now also recently A
Deadly fire at an apartment Block in
xinjiang killed 10 people and injured
nine and what's being blamed for why so
many people were killed and hurt by this
was the coveted lockdown measures which
reportedly delayed firefighters from
being able to reach the victims so I'm
sure everyone knows that China has maybe
the strictest coveted restrictions they
have had those severe restrictions this
entire time and unlike other countries
that took the virus very seriously but
later eased up the restrictions as
vaccines were rolled out and as other
treatments were rolled out China has
just been strict this entire time using
up very little like we've seen these
places like New Zealand and Australia
for example that were strict on travel
and these other things during much of
2020 and 2021 but then eventually their
population was exposed to the virus once
it became more manageable China on the
other hand has been sticking to covet
zero AKA Dynamic covid which includes
everything from having negative tests
required for people to enter a business
or public place to government supervised
quarantines to lockdowns when cases are
detected in significant enough numbers
even just this year there were of course
lockdowns in Shanghai and there was also
that shutdown that took place a few
weeks ago at Disney World it seems like
just with all these restrictions with
how long it's been going on people are
just reaching their boiling point and
certainly policy C's like these can last
a lot longer in a place like China than
they could in the United States I mean
here in the U.S people through a fit
because they had to wear masks in public
for longer than two weeks it became more
than just you know two weeks to slow the
spread so people
went ballistic over in China they've
been dealing with this stuff for a lot
longer and much more severe restrictions
people I think just ultimately only have
so much patience for this and the only
the other problem that Xi Jinping has
right now is that he has to ease up on
restrictions to keep people happy while
at the same time not make it look like
the Chinese government is changing its
mind because that could lower their
credibility in terms of how they see it
like I I would do this as like okay well
he's just looking at how covet has
changed it's not killing as many people
we have the tools to deal with it so it
makes sense that the government would
switch their position but in China the
sort of idea is that if he decides to
back off of covet zero then it would
suggest that he was wrong to Institute
it in the first place and so they have
to stick with this Zero Tolerance
approach to covid
um even as it may end up looking like
more and more of a failure and not
sustainable anymore so Xi Jinping is
backed into a corner the entire country
has to respond by doing these protests
I've seen people talk about how protests
in China are common but long-lasting
protests and protests in so many places
throughout the country are much much
less common and we'll see if this is
able to stand up in terms of the numbers
China is recording about 3 000 new
coveted cases a day which is a lot more
than they were admitting to at least you
know earlier on in the pandemic like
there was times where there was this
little surge at the beginning of this
year but during much of the time when
the world was dealing with the most
severe uh coveted outbreaks China wasn't
having too much of a problem with it
which is crazy to see because they have
a population of 1.4 billion people and
they would say oh well we only had 100
new cases today or 200 new cases today
and people either suspect that they were
so strict with their lockdowns and
coveted measures that they were able to
achieve that other people say they were
clearly fudging the numbers but
regardless of what they were doing
before now they're saying 3 000 is the
number that they're getting just about
every day a it's hard to predict where
this story is going to go next
especially because protests so often in
China are short-lived but at the same
time this covet zero policy seems
unsustainable and it seems like covet is
not going to be completely eradicated at
least not anytime soon and so the
government of China will eventually have
to adapt and bring about some changes
but the question is will a bunch of
people be jailed and maybe killed before
that happens or will there be some sort
of sensible policy change that comes to
China in the near future I'm rooting of
course for some sort of peaceful ending
to this all to still take the virus very
seriously but to ease up on the
restrictions because it seems like after
three years people are just not willing
to deal with it anymore we're learning
more details about the Colorado Springs
mass shooting that took place at an LGBT
nightclub on November 19th and much of
the conversation has been surrounding
the shooter's motivations because it's
being investigated as a hate crime and
on top of this being just a horribly
tragic act there's also this political
component to it this culture War
component to it because of all the
different issues that this overlaps with
it's not just gun safety it's also
right-wing media stochastic terrorism
LGBT rights and all these other issues
and so that's why there has been a lot
of attention to this shooting in
particular and also just sort of the
updates as to what we know about it this
time it's maybe more necessary to
discuss the motivations of the shooter
than in other cases because it overlaps
with all these different issues there's
also the concern that this specific type
of mass shooting could happen in the
future because the right is responding
to it by stoking the fire their
fear-mongering even more about gender
affirm and care for example here's
Tucker Carlson doing just that on his
Fox News propaganda show so these
horrifying murders in Colorado over the
weekend quickly became a a pretext for
yet more censorship of your speech you
are responsible for this they told you
because you said the wrong things you
are guilty of stochastic terrorism
inspiring Violence by your beliefs
Anderson Lee Aldrich committed mass
murder because you complained about the
sexualizing of children
every time you object to drag time story
hour for fifth graders or point out that
genital mutilation is being committed on
minors which it is every time you say
that you are putting people's lives at
risk so Tucker here talking about the
sexualizing of children and genital
mutilation to rile up his audience
essentially he acts like his audience is
being under attack by these people who
think that there are right-wing media
hosts who are stochastic terrorists and
also this has to do with free speech
somehow really well done in terms of
propaganda by Tucker Carlson but not
great in terms of lowering the
temperature right now especially after a
mass shooting when we don't want to see
this type of thing happen ever again and
then as we discussed last week there are
other voices on the right who are taking
the path of victim blaming in terms of
responding to this here's daily wire
commentator Matt Walsh saying that oh
well people should just stop dressing up
and drag I guess if you want to avoid
mass shootings at nightclubs and this
sort of thing let's take another listen
to that but why should we be the only
ones explaining instead of asking why we
oppose it so much we should ask why they
support it so much that according to
them they will keep doing it at the risk
of life and limb
why is it so important to you to
cross-dress in front of children
why is it so important why do you need
to do it why
is it worth the cost that you claim
you're paying for it
why do you have to do this why can't you
just not do it
if it is really causing all this chaos
again that's your version I don't uh uh
agree with that you're exaggerating but
according to you that's what you're
saying
is it why look if only you didn't wear
that dress in public you wouldn't have
been cat called that's basically the
type of logic that Matt Walsh is
applying here he's blaming the victim
this is also coming from supposedly
someone who is pro-freedom he's so
pro-freedom I guess that he doesn't want
people to feel empowered to live their
life the way that they want to live
without risk of getting shot uh at by
people who irrationally hate them now to
add another layer of complexity to this
story it was found out that late last
week the perpetrator has told their
attorneys that they are non-binary and
immediately right-wingers ran with this
story saying that look we're Vindicated
the right had nothing to do with this
the shooter was actually a member of the
LGBT community so therefore it can't be
right wing stochastic terrorism that led
to this when really there's a
possibility that this person could just
be trolling and they're only now coming
out as non-binary Airy when they lived
their entire life as a male and they're
doing so either to avoid hate crime
prosecution or to just Troll and make a
point to a right-wing audience we just
don't know the the facts of it yet but
still that hasn't stopped as people like
Tucker Carlson from going out there and
saying look we're Vindicated this proves
that there was nothing to be upset with
the right about and let's take a look at
it do you remember when Brandi said
drozny told you several hundred times
that the accused shooter Anderson Lee
Aldrich was inspired by hatred for the
non-binary community that he learned on
this show do you remember that
well actually it turns out we discovered
last night that Anderson Lee Aldrich is
drum roll please part of the non-binary
community he doesn't hate them he is one
in a court filing aldrich's lawyers
wrote this quote Anderson Aldrich is
non-binary they use they them pronouns
and for the purposes of all former
filings will be addressed as mix Aldrich
Aldrich that's the shooter the
non-binary shooter
let that sink in so look at Tucker
Carlson there just believing this thing
whole cloth saying that oh yeah the
shooter could not have been a right-wing
person trying to commit an anti-lgbt
hate crime because they themselves
identify as non-binary now I'm not going
to Discount the possibility that this
person legitimately is non-binary but it
all seems very convenient that we're
only hearing about this now from the
person after they've committed this
horrible act and now that they're being
investigated for potential hate crimes
like this could easily just be the
person trolling and trying to get a rise
out of these types of figures like
Tucker and play into the culture war and
you best believe that it turns out if it
turns out that this is a hoax in this
person really never was non-binary
doesn't actually identify this way well
Tucker won't really have all that much
egg on his face because he just won't
talk about this ever again that's what
we normally see happen with these types
of things and they can also just act as
if like oh well this may makes the left
look bad anyway because see how messed
up it is that anyone can just say that
they are non-binary or just say that
they're a man or say that they're a
woman and everyone else has to believe
them even though that's not strictly
speaking what the left's position is
it's if you give a legitimate effort to
live a certain way or another then you
should be respected as whoever you
identify as but it doesn't mean that you
can shoot a bunch of people at a
nightclub and then all of a sudden claim
that you're non-binary and then everyone
has to believe you at your word I mean
clearly you can be skeptical about that
sort of thing but that's the latest on
the right wing and their reaction to
this Colorado Springs shooting they are
blaming the victims they're saying more
horrible things about gender affirming
care they're talking about how the left
wants to sexualize children and they're
claiming that oh we actually don't have
anything to worry about on our side
because clearly this person was part of
the LGBT community just absolutely
despicable what has been coming from the
right on this issue in the past couple
of weeks
so we just had another election here in
the United States a couple of weeks ago
and one would imagine that around now
would be the time for Republicans to
start unveiling some specific examples
of voter fraud that supposedly happened
across the U.S in these 2022 midterms
and it's because they've been focusing
on it non-stop as an issue for their
party they've also started a bunch of
state-level law enforcement units that
were set up to investigate specific
voter fraud instances and so one would
think that with this being their first
opportunity to unveil the truth about
double voting by democrats and Democrats
voting for their dead grandma and people
putting the wrong kind of sauce on the
ballot and all these different things
you'd think that they would be talking
about this stuff non-stop but actually
they've been very much hush-hush and
that's because in Florida Georgia and
Virginia were these election fraud
agencies were created all backed by
Republicans they just don't have the
examples to put forward to people and it
shouldn't be much of a surprise that
they're coming up short because we know
and we've known this whole time that
voter fraud is incredibly rare in the
United States every study that we have
on this the breaded Center of Justice
study for example show that it's like a
handful of cases out of billions of
votes cast across many many different
election cycles that you have someone
who's provably committed fraud and many
of the examples of voter fraud from the
2020 election were actually Republicans
who were voting for Trump thinking that
they were making up the difference
because the left was supposedly
committing so much fraud surprise
surprise they weren't but the Trump
people in some cases were and of course
voting twice voter fraud in general is
just rare because it's the type of thing
that could get you sent to prison and
you're risking potential jail time for
one vote that's probably not going to
make the difference in an election it's
probably going to end up being in
concert sequential so it just doesn't
seem like a fair trade for the average
person to want to make that's why when
DeSantis wanted to do his voter fraud
stunt earlier this year and find people
to charge an arrest for voter fraud he
had to choose people who thought that
they actually were able to legally vote
thought that they had their rights
restored from the ballot measure in
Florida back in 2018 on her storing
felon voter rights and it's only these
Fringe cases that you can really find to
really make your case for how this is
supposedly existing all across the
country
there's just not that many cases of
people willingly doing this and so a
special task force in all these states
never really made sense but of course it
was just to appeal to right-wing voters
uh but even so they're not succeeding at
doing that because they're not able to
come up with at least just a couple of
cases to parade out to people and say
that this is systemic across the entire
country it's only been a couple weeks so
maybe we'll just have to give them more
time but sadly Republican voters will
just look at this all and even if
there's a lack of evidence they'll say
oh see that means the Democrats have
gotten especially good at rigging the
elections because they can cover their
tracks so easily and it means that we
have to pour even more resources into
trying to catch them I will say though
that the voter fraud thing does seem
like it's calming down after uh this
2022 midterm cycle the only person
that's really trying to make it a focal
point is Carrie Lake who lost her
election in Arizona but these other
trumpian candidates like Doug mastriano
and Tudor Dixon and Michigan they've
just decided to concede so at least for
now the voter fraud lies are taking a
break but I do think that they'll be
back in 2024 if Trump decides to run and
if he ultimately ends up losing either
the primary or the general so they're
taking a break from this narrative now
but you best believe it's probably going
to come back you know I should really
count up all the times that we've talked
about Elon musk's purchase of Twitter
this year on the show and on the bonus
show because it seems like every other
day we've been talking about this whole
Saga because before the deal was made
there was all this back and forth there
were questions about whether Elon could
actually buy Twitter and then if he
could back out from the deal and then
ever since he's taken over there's been
all these updates as to what the hell is
happening over at that company and I
find it important to provide the updates
because it's one of these things where
you have this high profile person the
richest person on the planet taking
control of one of the most important
social media sites and he's been making
a lot of mistakes and costing himself
and the company a lot of money in the
process and there's this question now
over whether Twitter will be able to
survive and it's turned into this total
Cesspool lately because of the low staff
and low level of enforcement well the
latest story is that Twitter is going to
be relaunching its verification program
this week earlier this month you may
remember that Twitter changed from
having those coveted blue checks
verifying high profile figures being
something that was instituted
automatically for people with a big
audience to something that you could pay
eight dollars a month for even though
even if you're not some high profile
figure yourself as long as you're
willing to pay up you could get that
highly coveted blue check now the first
draft of this proposal failed miserably
because with the rollout and the lack of
moderation there was just a great deal
of impersonation accounts with people
paying for the blue check and it became
clear you just wouldn't be able to trust
anyone with this new system you couldn't
tell if people were actually who they
say they were then Elon jumped in and
said that in person haters and parity
accounts would receive a permanent
suspension with no warning you had
people impersonating Elon himself and
you had one account impersonating the
pharmaceutical giant Eli Lilly which
tweeted that insulin was free causing
the company's stock to take a nosedive
so it's all had some great consequences
and it's all been chaos and even aside
from all of this is the reality
um that's you know it's really taken the
whole point of being verified if you can
just pay for the service because like
there's really not that much clout to
being able to afford the Eight dollar a
month charge and at the same time like
the point of verification is to to to
know with certainty that people are who
they are you take that away if it's
something that people can just pay for
and there's really no sense in just an
average Joe being verified because who's
trying to impersonate their account to
begin with nobody uh so Elon has been
making so many different mistakes now
what he's trying to do is add this
color-coded system for verification he
tweeted recently sorry for the delay
we're tentatively launching verified on
Friday next week gold check for
companies gray check for government blue
for individuals celebrity or not and all
verified accounts will be manually
authenticated before check activates
painful but necessary so from that post
it's unclear how exactly their
verification process is going to work
and if you're even improving anything
from the first round that was a total
disaster like maybe an individual user
will no longer be able to pretend to be
a company or a government agency but
that doesn't help all that much because
there's still plenty of celebrities that
they can and still impersonates because
they will have the same color check as
the people who were high profile I think
this idea altogether is a total mess
like I think you need a verification
process so that news outlets and just
everyday people can know that when they
see someone is tweeting something that
it's actually that person and not
someone else another problem Twitter
will continue to have is all these
employees leaving how are you going to
have enough people to manually verify
all of these different accounts it just
sounds like a total nightmare we know of
course that elon's goal behind launching
this paid service was to increase
Revenue over the company because they've
been having a difficulty doing that and
when you're subject to the whims of
advertisers it means that you're not
well Diversified as a con as a company
because you know you're just not all
that Recession Proof like if companies
have less money to advertise then your
Revenue will plummet and I'm certain
that that probably happened this year
with the scale down uh in the economy
that took place in 2022 so maybe maybe
they want to just open up other streams
of income so you can be a little bit
more well balanced but it doesn't
necessarily mean that this is the right
way to go about doing it this never
seemed to be the solution to me anyway
paying for verification especially when
you look into the numbers like there are
apparently about 200 million Twitter
users and they say that that doesn't
really include debt accounts and
accounts that people haven't used in a
long time but I think the realistic
number is probably significantly less
than that and if if you also have like a
smaller portion of people who are
willing to actually pay for the Twitter
blue how much money are you really going
to be able to raise from this system is
it going to be anything that compares to
the five billion dollars of Revenue that
you did in 2021 is it going to make that
much of a difference and if so does it
make up for the lack of credibility that
you have uh the sort of trustworthiness
that you give up by changing this
verification system over my sense is
that it's probably not going to be worth
it but Elon is trying he's trying to
come up with innovative ideas to bring
about an extra stream of Revenue coming
in but this one seems to be a total
disaster and it doesn't seem like it's
working well and that people are open to
it and finally another Elon Musk story
to finish off today's program Elon Musk
has said that he will support Ron
DeSantis for president in 2024 if the
Florida governor decides to run for
president earlier this year musk
followed in the footsteps of people like
Dave Rubin and Tulsi gabbard who were
supposedly on the left before but then
drifted more and more to the right for
one reason or another and people often
question the genuineness of these
Transformations Elon has now joined them
he's previously said that he's voting
Republican and his followers should do
the same because that would lead to
divided government after the 2022
midterms to quote curb the worst
excesses of both parties the real reason
of course that billionaires like musk
like divided government is because it
provides some certainty that nothing is
going to get done legislative at least
nothing major is going to get done and
it's good for their stock prices because
it just goes to show that the boat is
not going to get rocked Elon was asked
to tweet whether he'd back to santis if
he decides to run for president and he
said yes going on to say my preference
for the 2024 presidency is somewhat
sensible and Centrist I had hoped that
would be the case for the Biden
Administration but have been
disappointed so far so DeSantis is
apparently sensible and Centrist or at
least much more sensible and Centrist
than Joe Biden is that's according to
Elon Musk I mean how delusional is that
like you have Ron DeSantis who is at the
center of every right-wing culture War
issue from trans people to immigration
to police to voter fraud he's far right
in all of these things and yet Biden who
was perhaps the most conservative option
Democrats had in the 2020 primaries who
was you know Centrist Barack Obama's
vice president he's too far left
apparently that's really trying to push
the Overton window in a rightward
direction if you ask me
I don't think that Elon actually thinks
this to be honest I think that he
recognizes that his fan base is mostly
right wing and he fell victim to
audience capture like so many people do
he's just telling his crowd what they
want to hear and uh you know he just
assesses that Republican control also
will be good for his net worth at least
for the short term so he's just pushing
right wing figures like DeSantis he also
probably assesses though that Trump
maybe passed his Prime and it's better
for him to distance himself more and
more from Trump because at this point
you know especially defending Trump is
just becoming more and more untenable so
there you go Elon Musk is falling
squarely into the DeSantis Camp which a
lot of Republicans have found themselves
doing recently because many are trying
to look more sensible they're trying to
pick the more decent option out there in
someone like DeSantis who has all of
Trump's policy stances but has presented
a lot more neatly and we'll have to see
how the endorsements shake out whether
this cohort of people who choose to
Santa over Trump will end up making a
difference especially someone like Elon
who has a cult-like following and many
of his people will decide to go the
DeSantis route because Elon is doing it
and it's definitely shaping up to be a
battle for the ages that's for sure all
right that's going to do it for today's
episode of the David Pacman show for
more content be sure to check out
today's bonus show if you are already a
member or Patron if you're not yet a
member or Patron become one might as
well right you could go to
joinpakman.com and sign up for a
membership or you could contribute over
at patreon at the five dollar level to
become able to access uh the bonus show
we'll see you all there and have a great
day everybody
foreign
is the non-profit that lets you send
cash directly to the world's poorest
household which is more cost effective
than so many other types of giving it's
how you know you're maximizing your
donations help us reach our goal of
fifteen thousand dollars by the end of
the year go to give
directly.org Pacman